welcome to this video playing Duquesne I
hope to pronounce it right Duquesne
probably an Enzo yeah new zone ok let's
play my check my Z Michigan and see him
what line is coming up with ok the one
of the main lines or the mainline fleet
um let's see the water am i playing here
Bishop e3 and I g3 if i remember
correctly
I really have forgotten what I'm playing
uh-huh okay now see far as hanging Eddie
for I saying hmm hmm should I have
played 93 don't know okay so night c
forum it's really a this is really a bit
of a problem hmm
should play d5 something like that I
don't know how completely have forgotten
the how how this is Sir oh this is
played interesting okay yes he foresaw
is doomed but maybe I get enough
activity one important ideas Sam to play
to play play at five I play d5 here yeah
okay now I'll see photos hanging which
is so of course a problem I could cover
it with Queen d3 for a moment at least
but then there's 95
however if he takes on c4 and goes
Bishop to g5 also look nice okay let's
grab this pie let's see what what's
going to happen some got a potentially
good piece on d5 but I can open up with
f5 I'd have some pieces near the King
night age five Ouija for those kind of
ideas no I need to activate anyway so
let's not think for too long mmm this is
surprising not sure where he wants to go
I understand that he's got a good Bishop
on d5 but my nan de force not shabby as
well Wow ok let's first take them take
on e6 is going to take F 2 mm
take here take f true hmm yeah it's not
totally convincing or Queenie too yeah
maybe Queenie to taking this okay but it
looks it looks dangerous right age five
he's got a five ok I probably need to
take first
if I've probably 9 h 5 years d 5 antenna
crew chief for now but i forgot about
green be one to be honest hmm gasps
smooth was not not very well thought out
can also maybe just take a 3some
possible rookie three I mean but came
group G for checkup I got night everyone
probably playable but not so clear maybe
he can he can take a three yeah this was
an additional problem Bishop takes rook
e8 stuff like that and down check here
yeah no use and well that I can just
taken just a retreat queen is covered
which is nothing special but at least
I'm not losing material but I really
feared after your 5 Bishop takes as a
rookie 8 or something
hmm maybe go one day I want reform and
went i'm going to keep the King save on
edge too yeah this is very dry but I've
got 46 seconds gras foie gras our third
game drone yeah it's just just nothing
at all happening especially considering
we've got opposite colored bishops yeah
this was complicated around here I felt
that this this looked risky yeah the
computer just prefers black clearly I
know I was I was optimistic that some
sort of night age 51 but I didn't really
I couldn't really make it work and it
did it really it really was good for
black my this is probably mistake a can
take a three with the book I feared that
this is a possible him I have to look
here child chicken I can shine check
here but after that i'm out of I'm out
of air I think nothing to do him he's
threatening stuff like that
computers is black is winning and if I
if I could really take and queen e cigs
and this was the lucky escape and now
this is really a completely dead yeah
the same which always makes for
interesting interesting games but I I
really have forgotten I have forgotten
the theory here completely and my guess
Bishop e3 is the wrong move it's it's
taking its taking first and then night
g3 isn't it something like that I really
have forgotten forgotten the theory oh
okay well thanks for watching